their eyes full of fear and fatigue
their belongings hurriedly packed in a
bag
taking their precious companions on an
unknown Journey
people from nearly 40 Villages near the
front line in the northeast of Ukraine
have been ordered to leave for safer
areas
there is no one in the neighborhood
everyone has already left I was the last
one there is a strong incoming fire a
man and a woman died the day before
yesterday the missile fell directly in
their yard the Russians are seven
kilometers away the
Ukrainian authorities say more than 100
000 Russian soldiers and 900 tanks are
increasingly attacking trying to retake
kupiansk and its surrounding areas
Ukraine recapture the city from Russian
forces last September
it's very dangerous because the other
side has accumulated a lot of ammunition
to attack a lot of artillery in a few
months that's why people leave
volunteers are going from Village to
Village persuading people to leave not
much convincing is needed
this Village about 30 kilometers from
the front line is mostly empty
escaping nearly daily shelling and a
possible second Russian occupation
people leave behind everything once
again the joy when Ukrainian forces
recapture this area has now been
replaced by fear
while the trauma of the Russian
occupation is still being felt some
residents are confident Ukrainian forces
can hold off the Russians this time
where will I go I can't just leave my
home my children grow and I have an I
have an old father I can't drag him with
me we sing and support our brothers from
the Armed Forces as much as we can
others couldn't take the stress of
constant shelling any longer at a
shelter in kharkif Lut Miller hopes to
find some relief
it is getting stronger and stronger
every day there are no breaks at all
constant incoming fire constantly the
forest smokes
there is no time to breathe
we didn't sleep at all
and do it one year but my patience has
run out I cannot take it anymore
picked up from the comfort of their
homes their lives now uprooted once more
hoping to find some sense of safety and
leaving their darkest moments behind
them for now
stepfather Al Jazeera in kupian's
District Eastern Ukraine